c'est on va prendre maintenant est la
direction de l'allemagne où le pentagone
va dépêcher 7000 soldats supplémentaires
nous vivons le début d'une guerre comme
il n'y en a jamais eu en europe en tout
cas pas depuis plus de 75 ans ce sont
les mots du chancelier allemand olaf
scholz face à la tentative de vladimir
poutine de rayer je cite l ukraine de la
carte on en parle avec vous
emmanuel chasse vous êtes avec nous vous
êtes notre correspondante à berlin le
chancelier allemand qui veut à tout prix
à éviter une extension de ce conflit à
d'autres pays européens l'allemagne
comme la france a essayé de jouer la
carte diplomatique mais pour l'heure
tout vole en éclats
oui tout à fait cette diplomatie a été
tenu en échec par les actions de
vladimir poutine et le chancelier
allemand la chaussée a utilisé des mots
très forts hier il a expliqué que la
journée du 24 février étaient un jour
terrible pour l'ukraine un jour sombre
pour l'europe et que cette guerre est
bien c'était la guerre faite par
vladimir poutine c'était la guerre de la
demir poutine at il dit à la fin d'un
premier discours est ensuite l'après
midi lorsqu'il a rencontré ses
partenaires du g7 il a il a averti il
faut absolument éviter que le conflit
s'étende au-delà de l'ukraine alors
alors ces propos sont évidemment fort
mais il reste des interrogations il ya
aussi des critiques ici en allemagne sur
ce que l'allemagne fait concrètement
pour pour aider son allié son allié
l'ukraine alors il ya eu ces sanctions
il ya eu cette sanction très attendue
mardi annoncé c'était la suspension de
ce gazoduc très controversé nord stream
2 qui n'a jamais qui n'a jamais été mis
en fonction mais dont l'usagé est
maintenant suspendu les certificats ont
été les certificats de conformité ont
été révoqués ça c'était une décision
qu'on attendait ici en allemagne que
beaucoup appelaient de leurs voeux
puisque ce gazoduc finalement s'il est
mis en circulation ça rendra l'allemagne
encore plus dépendante du gaz russe elle
est déjà à hauteur de 50 % de ses
besoins
énergétique donc c'était un premier pas
un autre passe sur les sanctions
bancaires bancaire et vous l'avez évoqué
un peu plus tôt nina en parlant du
système bancaire swift apparemment
l'allemagne bloque toujours sur cette
mesure ne l'a pas encore interdite
critique également à l'encontre du
gouvernement allemand pour ne pas avoir
envoyé d'armes défensives et alors que
kiev avait demandé il ya quelques
semaines déjà en allemagne de l'équipe
et notamment
notamment en armes défensives
l'allemagne a répondu en mettant à
disposition de kiev cent mille casques
dits défensifs des casques qui ne sont
toujours pas arrivés en ukraine
autres autres vous l'avez évoqué
rapidement à propos de cette suspension
du nord stream 2 vous l'avez dit
l'allemagne dépend donc fortement du gaz
russe à hauteur de 50% on s'attend donc
à des pénuries du moins à de fortes
hausses des prix en matière énergétique
tout à fait alors on s'y attend du côté
du gouvernement la ministre des affaires
étrangères anna lena bareback avait dit
face aux actions russes en ukraine avait
dit nous sommes sans voix mais nous ne
sommes pas sans moyens et l'allemagne ne
souhaite ne souhaite pas éviter ces
sanctions même si elle sait qu'elle aura
à payer un lourd tribut un tribut
financier on s'attend à ce que les prix
les coûts énergétiques augmentent de
façon conséquente ici en allemagne c'est
une peur qui est partagé par les
allemands les allemands qui ne
souhaitait pas non plus que leur
gouvernement envoie des âmes mais des
allemands qui montre aussi leur
solidarité au peuple ukrainien hier soir
des milliers de personnes se sont
rassemblées un peu partout en allemagne
ici à berlin devant la porte de
brandebourg pour affirmer leur soutien
au peuple ukrainien mais sur certains
des certaines des pancartes qu'on a pu
voir il y avait ce n'est pas tout de
montrer leur solidarité la solidarité ne
suffit pas donc une opinion ici en
allemagne très divisé une opinion qui ne
voient aussi pas d'un oeil favorable
la façon dont le gouvernement allemand
gère cette crise avec c'est assez
intéressant de noter plus de 40% des
allemands qui aimerait bien revoir un
gala merkel la table des négociations en
tout cas sur l'échiquier diplomatique
pour négocier avec vladimir poutine
emmanuel chasse en direct de berlin
merci à vous on va continuer